we are absolutely destroying these
horrible regulations I haven't seen
anything like the regulatory reductions
that have taken place let's cut the red
tape who is in favor of regulations that
aren't working we have undertaken a
historic effort to massively reduce job
crushing regulations and we're imposing
a new rule which mandates that for every
one new regulation too old regulations
must be eliminated Donald Trump promised
at the beginning of his presidency to
slash regulations and after his first
year he's delivered more than almost
anybody predicted Washington's
regulatory reformers have infiltrated
the halls of power and are attempting to
engineer the most ambitious pruning of
the executive branch in over three
decades it's a bright spot in a
presidency that has otherwise been the
opposite of libertarian trade wars
travel bans and big spending increases
Trump has appointed real reformers to
carry out his deregulatory agenda Betsy
DeVos at education Rick Perry at energy
Scott Gottlieb at the Food and Drug
Administration Ajit PI at the FCC one of
the most influential administrators is
Naomi Rao Trump's appointee to oversee
cost-benefit analyses for the entire
regulatory juggernaut who came to the
White House after founding the Center
for the study of the administrative
State at George Mason University I think
that there are a lot of very strongly
reform minded people who have come into
the administration right in occupying a
number of the senior political
appointments and and they're very
committed to you know regulatory reform
and rolling back some of these burdens
that have been imposed over the past
five ten fifteen years so what is Trump
deregulated in his first year the
President signed 15 regulatory repeals
via the congressional review act or
fourteen more times than the law had
been used the previous two decades gone
our Obama cares individual mandate the
EPA's clean power plan and the
Department of Education x' kangaroo
court style guidance on campus sexual
assaults in addition to the two-for-one
executive order Trump has also required
agencies to impose an aggregate
regulatory cost each year of zero
the neverending growth of red tape in
America has come to a sudden screeching
and beautiful halt we're not just you
know going to eliminate some small
insignificant rules but we also have to
have a negative regulatory cost budget
you know which is what we had for 2017
and we went even below that and I think
it's the first time since at least we've
been keeping records that there's been a
year like that you know we're also
encouraging the agencies to look at
deregulation not just from the numbers
side you know many agencies are peeling
back guidance documents or streamlining
paperwork burdens and all of that I
think is having an impact the
free-market enthusiasts at the
Competitive Enterprise Institute a
Washington DC think-tank have been
tallying new regulations annually for
the past 25 years in 2017 they found the
administration cut the number of pages
in the Federal Register by more than 1/3
and the 3281 new rules amounted to the
lowest count since records began being
kept in the mid-1970s I haven't seen
personally anything like the regulatory
reductions that have taken place the
Competitive Enterprise Institute slide
Wayne Cruz is already calling Donald
Trump the least regulatory president of
all Trump has gone after saying for
example the waters of the United States
rule EPA so-called waters of the United
States rule is one of the worst examples
of federal regulation it's welcoming to
see the FCC turn back the so-called net
neutrality rule I'm impressed and
unimpressed at the same time I love what
has happened and I want it to continue
but to really address all of that you've
got to get Congress to act in other
words the executive branch can rearrange
the scope and process of enforcement but
only legislators can repeal the
underlying laws the million-dollar
question is how much impact will the
Trump administration's regulatory tweaks
have on individual industries and the
overall economy
so by are very kind of conservative
internal estimates we estimate that the
regulations that we've pulled back are
saving more than eight billion dollars
and maybe that sounds small but when you
think of it in the context that the cost
of regulations increases every year I
think
it's actually pretty impressive I think
another number that's important is that
we are revisiting or have postponed over
1500 rules that were on the agenda and
you know some of those rules may end up
going forward but I think it it
demonstrates the magnitude of what we're
reconsidering is this the first real
challenge to the kind of automatic
growth of the regulatory state that
we've seen in you know a solid
generation here I think so yes
we've done more in our first year than
any president since we've been keeping
records the numbers that have been
reduced in the Trump administration
pretty significant when he rolled back
or withdrew or withheld 1500 of Obama's
regulations they're not all significant
regulations by any stretch but it's a
start
and remember Obama said I have a pen and
phone and like if Congress doesn't act
we can go around Congress and act Trump
has a pen and phone to any President
does and it can be used within the rule
of law to advance Liberty rather than
curtail it though Trump met his target
last year can he do it again or has the
easy stuff already been plucked I think
in 2018 he's gonna have a much tougher
time the job of rolling back to 4:1 when
you're acting alone as president and you
can't make law on your own the the
barrier that you run into
you should run out of low-hanging fruit
so how much can you do now you got two
for one in place I know you want to try
to do three for one next year but how
much latitude does the executive branch
there's plenty of bad regulation that's
still out there that we can work on
rolling back to really get at sort of
the core of the regulatory state you're
going to need statutory reform the house
has passed a series of reform bills that
focus on the process by which the
executive branch makes its rules these
have names like searching for and
cutting regulations that are
unnecessarily burdensome act or scrub
the regulations from the executive in
need of scrutiny act or reins and so on
all are currently languishing in the
Senate where the slim Republican
majority includes senators who have
expressed concern that deconstructing
the administrative state will have a
negative impact on the health and safety
of Americans now your progressive
friends will say that what you're doing
is making the world more dangerous
what's your basic response to that
framework so I think Congress has
through a mass of statutes insured
essentially that we live in a very
highly regulated society and there's a
limit to how much the executive branch
can do to undo that we're not looking to
undo health and safety protections that
are required by law right definition the
regulations that we're turning back are
not working for the public so can
libertarians expect more progress in the
midterm election year of 2018 to the
extent regulatory reforms happen in a
year like this one that's going to be so
contentious and already is I think it
would be something lesser it would be
something on the order of more
disclosure of regulations I know there's
some bipartisan support for that but
sadly in terms of rolling back
regulations this year Trump is pretty
much on his own what's in front of you
we want to reduce the cumulative
regulatory burdens on the American
people as much as possible the agencies
now really have to go back and think
about which of their regulations are no
longer working it's a good government
kind of policy mean who is in favor of
regulations that aren't working
[Music]